The 2019 iPad Air has just been released,
but there’s a problem, it’s basically
the 2017 10.5” iPad Pro, but with a newer
processor and a few missing features, for
almost as much cash.
And we’ve seen the 2017 Pro for as low as
$400 on Amazon, even cheaper than the Air,
so make sure to check the links in the description
to see if it’s still on sale.
So what’s the difference?
And how do you choose?
Well, let’s compare them!
On the backside, they look almost identical,
except that the old Pro has a camera bump
and flash.
On the top edge, you’ll find two extra speakers
on the Pro, which is the biggest reason to
get the Pro instead.
We also get the same smart connector on the
side of each iPad for the smart keyboard.
On the front, they look literally identical.
They get the same resolution, same laminated
display, same true tone and p3 wide-color
gamut, but the Air is actually missing ProMotion
technology.
What this means is that it allows the display
to refresh at up to 120Hz and dynamically
go down to match the frame rate of the content
you’re viewing to save battery life.
As you can see in this slow-mo clip of the
2018 iPad Pro and 2019 iPad Air, the difference
in the smoothness of ProMotion compared to
the Air is huge!
And trust me, you’ll feel this difference
every day!
Not only that, but ProMotion lowers the latency
of the Apple Pencil as well, and you can easily
see the difference compared to the iPad Air
which doesn’t have it.
The 2017 iPad Pro’s display also gets brighter,
at 600 nits compared to 500 on the new Air,
so that means it supports HDR video.
Now let’s listen to a quick sound comparison
between these iPads.
As you guys heard, most of the sound is coming
from the right side on the Air, so you get
a much better listening experience on the
Pro, not to mention actual stereo separation
in landscape mode.
This is gonna be huge if you’re into gaming,
allowing you to easily hear footsteps around
you in shooting games.
Before we compare performance and gaming,
let’s compare the cameras.
The 2017 iPad Pro actually has a better rear
camera than the Air, at 12MP instead of 8.
This means you can take better photos and
shoot 4K video.
Here’s a quick photo comparison so you can
see the difference.
Getting into performance, the 2019 iPad Air
gets the new A12 processor from the iPhone
XS, complete with the neural engine, and the
2017 iPad Pro gets an older A10X chip, but
the Pro actually gets 4GB of RAM compared
to 3 on the new Air.
Comparing Geekbench 4 scores, the Air is 22%
faster in single-core and 21% faster in multi-core,
which is definitely a difference, but not
that much.
Comparing the Metal graphics performance test,
the old iPad Pro is actually 35% faster than
the new Air, which affects gaming performance
more than processor performance does.
Now testing the Antutu benchmark, the new
Air is now 35% faster than the old Pro, a
pretty good difference.
We decided to test a more realistic test by
exporting a 1 minute 4K HEVC video, and the
iPad Air finished 18 seconds sooner than the
old Pro, which is surprisingly not that big
of a difference.
Now let’s compare gaming performance.
Playing Fortnite, both iPads can play at 60
frames per second, but the old Pro is limited
to Medium graphics in this setting, while
the new Air can run 60fps on High settings.
In game, both of them are incredibly smooth
and responsive, with no noticeable dropped
frames at 60 fps.
The biggest difference I noticed was actually
the speakers.
It was hard to hear footsteps on the Air with
speakers only on one side.
So it seems like the Air is going to have
better gaming performance with higher settings
in certain game, but both iPads run games
perfectly.
The Air also gets newer cellular and wireless
tech like Bluetooth 5.0, simultaneous dual-band
WiFi and Gigabit-class LTE.
So here’s the question, since you can find
the 2017 iPad Pro for $500-$570 brand new
or for only $400 refurbished on Amazon, is
the extra performance of the 2019 iPad Air
worth missing out on the iPad Pro’s awesome
ProMotion technology and four-speaker audio?
Going back to a non-Pro iPad feels really
weird because it’s missing ProMotion, it
feels like the processor is slow but it really
isn’t.
Same for the speakers, once you experience
four speakers on the Pro, it’s really hard
to go back.
In my opinion, those features make the 2017
10.5” iPad Pro a much better value than
the Air, as long as you can find it on sale
below $600, which it currently is on Amazon,
so make sure to check the links in the description
below.
The only caveat is that the Pro will lose
software support in 5 years instead of 7 on
the Air, but when that happens, if you do
wait that long to upgrade your iPad, you won’t
really mind since you enjoyed the ProMotion
tech and better speakers for all of those
years.
If you enjoyed this comparison, hit that subscribe
button!
Thank for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next one!